Estoy cansada de intentar fingir las apariencias.
Un amigo me dijo que estoy quebrada no pobre, y que hay una diferencia.
Vivo sin cable, sin membresía al gimnasio,
y sin citas para manicura.
Descubrí que puedo peinarme sola.
No hay ahorros para la jubilación,
ni huchas.
Agoté eso hace mucho tiempo.
No hay un condominio costoso que me dé rendimientos,
ni ningún marido para respaldarme.
Los meses de pago lento y sin pago han diezmado mi crédito.
Los cobradores llaman constantemente
leyendo literalmente de un texto
primero expresando compasión educada por mi situación
y luego exigiendo arreglos de pago que posiblemente no pueda cumplir.
Los amigos se preguntan en privado cómo alguien tan bien educado
podría estar en caída libre económica.
Todavía soy tan talentosa como siempre e inteligente como un látigo,
pero el trabajo escasea,
principalmente dentro y fuera de la consultoría temporal.
A los 55 aprendí a fingir alegría,
pero ya no hay muchas oportunidades de trabajo.
No recuerdo exactamente cuándo se detuvo,
pero no puedo negar haber ingresado
al mundo incierto de antes y solía ser.
Ya no estoy segura de a dónde pertenezco.
Lo que sí sé es que docenas de solicitudes de trabajo en línea
parecen simplemente desaparecer en un agujero negro.
Me pregunto qué será de mí.
Hasta ahora mi salud se ha mantenido,
pero me duele el cuerpo... ¿o es mi espíritu?
Las mujeres sin hogar solían ser invisibles para mí,